businesses are closing unemployment is
rising inflation is soaring and the
local currency depreciated by at least
50% and now for the first time in its
history
Lebanon is defaulting on paying its debt
1.2 billion dollars is due on Monday the
country is facing its worst economic
crisis in decades Prime Minister has
sandy who took office in January after
massive protests toppled the previous
government told the nation his
administration will work on
restructuring the debt which has become
too much for the country to bear our
hard currency reserves are at a critical
record low as a result the Republic of
Lebanon is forced to default the coming
March 9th obligation on the euro bond
these funds must be channeled towards
securing the basic necessities for the
Lebanese people people have been on the
streets for months demanding a new
leadership they have little faith in a
government appointed by the old
political class they accuse of
corruption demonstrators have also
vented their anger at banks for imposing
capital controls but bankers are blaming
the authorities for looking for an easy
way out restructuring the public that
seems to be a way to avoid the other
reforms that are necessary to jumpstart
the economy and to solve the crisis
which is essentially restructuring the
public sector some parties in Lebanon
have been used to look at the public
sector as a source of benefits and
favors to their political constituency
international donors have made clear
there will be no assistance unless
reforms are carried out it's not just
about implementing reforms Lebanon's new
government does not have many friends it
is seen by the United States and its
allies as controlled by Hezbollah an
Iranian backed group they consider a
terrorist organization and they have
been trying to contain Iran's growing
influence in the Middle East the only
option to secure foreign funding and
without risking further isolation is
through the International Monetary Fund
but Hezbollah the power broker in
government has rejected an IMF bailout
it says it would involve
taxes and calls the institution a tool
of the United States I mean in case
Hezbollah signs signs up to the IMF they
will lose some of the sovereignty
they've won in the 2018 elections the
first election that they've won since
2005 and if they lose that power
this means that they've conceded some
sort of defeat to the IMF and to the
international community and to the
United States
Lebanon's financial crisis has entered a
new stage and there doesn't seem to be a
rescue plan and as conditions worsen for
the people many are warning of further
unrest Zeneca dar al jazeera babe